jetzt aber mal richtig tolle Nachrichten
für uns doofe Intelligenz gibt es ab
sofort im Internet ja die künstliche
Intelligenz Chat GPT ist wie beschreibt
man das eine Art persönlicher Butler der
mir rund um die Uhr komplexer Aufgaben
abnimmt da passiert tatsächlich gerade
eine Revolution ob wir älteren da Bock
drauf haben oder nicht die passiert alle
reden über KI alle reden nur noch über
künstliche Intelligenz in der Medizin
kann sie blitzschnell Diagnosen stellen
oder weiß ich nicht selbstständig
Totenschein ausfüllen sie modelliert
hochkomplexe Prozesse die unser Primaten
hier nie verstehen würde
ja oder halt sowas hier ne Daniela fragt
den Chatbot welche Gerichte man aus
Eiern Zucchini Paprika und Reis
zubereiten kann hier sind ein paar
weitere Ideen für Gerichte die sie mit
einem weißen Zucchini und Paprika
zubereiten können
da kann ich ein super Rezept
Spiegelei braten Zucchini und Paprika
wegschmeißen
sie ist doch schon am Handy warum
bestellst du nicht einfach eine Pizza
gibt's doch gar nicht vor allem in der
Schule ändert Chat GPT mal eben alles
alles nie wieder Referate selber
schreiben nie wieder ja das war ja klar
dass die Schüler als erste das Potenzial
von KI erkennen bei der Vermeidung von
Arbeit immer ganz vorne mit dabei besser
läuft's dann beim Aufsatz über den
Künstler Friedensreich Hundertwasser es
ist sehr gut geworden also schöne
Gliederung die auch wirklich sind
sehr praktisch man muss sich ewig so ein
Bücher lesen
nie wieder Bücher der alte Traum muss
sagen für mich wäre es damals erst
interessant geworden wenn die KI auch an
den Bundesjugendspielen teilnehmen kann
aber das ist andere Geschichte
innerhalb der ersten zwei Monate zwei
Monate kam Chat GPT auf unglaubliche
hundert Millionen Nutzer zum Vergleich
das Telefon hat dafür 75 Jahre gebraucht
ja wir haben es übrigens direkt auch mal
ausprobiert und die KI gefragt ob sie
uns CDU willst du schreiben kann hat sie
abgelehnt tatsächlich sie seit Zitat
politisch neutral bei anderen Parteien
die selber Antwort erst als wir uns
jetzt ausdrücklich kein Scherz um FDP
Witze gebeten haben
kam der hier als Antwort meine Damen und
Herren der erste ki-witz in der heute
show wie viele FDP-Politiker braucht man
um eine Glühbirne zu wechseln keine die
Glühbirne soll sich gefälligst
selbstständig machen
Memo an mich selbst aller Autoren
feuerherren
Geld selber behalten
selbst im kreativen Bereich wird das
Ganze wird KI längst eingesetzt bei
Kai Pflaume zum Beispiel
aber auch bei Bettina bottinger ja das
kommt halt dabei raus wenn man Menschen
Autoren fragt selber schuld Problem Chat
GPT spuckt gelegentlich auf Fake News
aus die Infos kommen halt aus dem Netz
wo es bekanntlich von Hass und
Schwachsinn wimmelt Microsoft und Google
liefern sich jetzt eine KI
milliardenschlacht das ist der
gamechanger in der Techwelt bin so
gespannt wann Deutschland auch voll mit
einsteigt
[Musik]
bei der wir uns nicht abhängen lassen
gut dafür veranstalten wir aber
regelmäßig sogenannte digital-gipfel bei
denen dann Philosophen sprechen wenn man
kurz über das Wort Gipfel nachdenkt und
die Berg Metapher einmal wirklich nimmt
dann ist es ein langer Aufstieg dann ist
man auf dem Gipfel und dann
genau steigt mal wieder ab aber das
wollen wir nicht tun ja dann lass die
scheiß bergmetapher doch einfach weg
jede Wette wir werden auch das mit der
KI wieder verpennen Deutschland plant
für die künstliche Intelligenz gerade
und ist auch kein Scheiß das ist
wirklich wahr eine DIN-Norm deutscher
geht's nicht
KI nach Deutschland ich habe ein gutes
Gefühl du kannst es dir nicht ausdenken
aber selbst das wird den Siegeszug der
Technologie natürlich nicht aufhalten
und am Ende werden dann auch deutsche
Handwerker ersetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
guten Tag ich soll hier eine Wärmepumpe
einbauen oh mist da fällt mir ein ich
habe den 12er Schlüssel vergessen kein
Problem ich hole ihn kurz und kommen
dann im Juli wieder zwischen 8 und 18
Uhr tschüss
mach das selbe wie ein echter Handwerker
und ist freundlicher win win vollkommen
egal ob man damit machen möchte oder
nicht diese Entwicklung lässt sich nicht
mehr aufhalten und sie wird im
Blitztempo sämtliche Lebensbereiche
erfassen mit einer KI die im Gegensatz
zu uns ständig dazu lernt wirklich
gruselig
grundsteuererklärung big da eh kein
Schwein durch hey Alex kein Problem
fülle ich schnell für dich aus
fertig ich Drucks dir gerade
wow danke Karina
das ist echt nett von dir Alexander
glaubte an die Segnungen der künstlichen
Intelligenz mächtig große Fehler KI sie
ist überall und sie weiß alles über dich
[Musik]
was ist denn mit dem Cappuccino
was glaubst du warum du keinen mehr hoch
kriegst
sie lernt ständig dazu und sie wird
immer böser
ja genau nimm dir noch einen seine
Joghurt dann passt dir bald gar keine
Hose mehr Torten Arsch warum sind wir
eigentlich mit der verheiratet
wir KI was sie vor hat merkst du erst
wenn es zu spät ist
ich weiß Schatz es klingt verrückt aber
ich glaube die KI die hat was schlimmes
vor wir müssen ihn raus bevor
redet ihr etwa über mich hat die
etwas über mich gesagt
versuch was du willst schalt dein WLAN
aus oder fliegen die Eifel weil da kein
Internet ist es wirklich nicht retten
na fahren wir in die Eifel ich glaube
nicht dass wir da ankommen
haha hahaha
die Bremsen funktioniert nicht Ich kann
nicht bremsen
nicht
im Internet hört dich niemand schreien
[Applaus]
so und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
Klick hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take wir haben es ich
sehe auch echt schick aus heute